[Musik]
die spitzen der französischen regierung
treten an zur trauerfeier
eine polizistin wurde opfer einer
islamistisch motivierten attacke der
stadt fühlt sich getroffen
warum wurde sie getötet weil ihre
kollegin in den augen dieses mannes
dessen name ich mich weigere zu nennen
die französische polizei und damit die
autorität des staates repräsentiert
achtung das fahrzeug die ordnungskräfte
und mit ihm der staat werden immer
wieder angegriffen
mal mit messern mal wie hier in der
pariser avenue mit feuerwerkskörpern
vertreter der polizei sind schmerzgrenze
überschritten
die gesellschaft verändert sich und wird
immer gewalttätiger
anstatt miteinander zu diskutieren und
mit wohlwollen und gelassenheit
miteinander umzugehen beschimpft man
sich lieber in die schlacht geworfen hat
sich nun eine gruppe aktive und
ehemalige offiziere der französischen
armee in einem öffentlichen appell
beklagt sie den niedergang frankreich
sind fordert den staat zum durchgreifen
auf andernfalls so die unverhohlene
drohung müssten die kameraden
einschreiten
wir treffen job ja fabre berner dank den
initiatoren der umstrittenen aktion der
pensionierte hauptmann der gendarmerie
nationale schlägt alarm die abg
in jeder stadt selbst in den kleinsten
städten mit 25.000 ein viertel in denen
ständig was passiert wir haben es mit
kleinsten gruppen die nicht länger das
gesetz akzeptieren
gemeint sind orte und ihre bewohner wie
hier tremblay etwas außerhalb von paris
die boni orte mit hoher
kriminalitätsrate und immer wieder
scharmützel mit der polizei
mohammad el hamma nie erlebt die
sozialen probleme hier jeden tag seit
der nahegelegene flughafen viele
beschäftigte wegen der krise nach hause
schickte nimmt etwa der bedarf an essen
spenden stetig zu ich finde das gut die
hilfe ist gut
es gibt leute die gegen korona in
schwierigkeiten geraten sind probleme
mit der arbeit haben und kein geld um
essen zu kaufen
rahmani war es um die probleme und die
konflikte hier wehrt sich aber gegen die
pauschalen angriffe der soldaten gegen
die banlieue sie wollen die gesellschaft
spalten ganz einfach darum geht es sie
wollen die gesellschaft spalten und
wählerschaft für die nächsten wahlen
tatsächlich hat vor allem die extreme
rechte die attacken der soldaten dankbar
aufgegriffen präsidentschaftskandidatin
marine le pen kommen sie in ihrem land
oder wahlkampf gerade recht für unruhen
und gewalt macht sie den präsidenten
verantwortlich
die bilanz ist dramatisch eine bilanz
die die franzosen nachdenklich machen
sollte denn es ist offensichtlich falls
ihr manuell mack und das wäre das größte
unglück für die franzosen wieder gewählt
wird würde das das allgemeine chaos
verdanken hat immer wieder von word
licht abschaum gesprochen der in der
boni lebe viele jugendliche in trommler
haben die nase von ständigen attacken
von rechtsaußen reichlich voll wenn man
in der wolle den vorstädten eine gruppe
jugendliche vor einem gebäude stehen
sieht heißt es oft klar verkaufen die
drogen klar passieren merkwürdige dinge
dabei ist das gar nicht gern wir hängen
manchmal nicht vor einem gebäude sondern
auf einem tablett
wir sind einfach da und lachen
miteinander wir wollen zeit miteinander
verbringen
ich denke dass es in den vorstädten
schwierig weil manche bewohner keine
arbeit haben und manche drogen gedealt
haben um geld aber die leute haben nur
das schlechte gesehen und das behalten
sie im kopf
sie schmeißen alle in einen topf sie
sagen nicht da gibt's auch andere die
sich anstrengen zu arbeiten sie machen
uns regelrecht schlecht wenn ich sehe
dass sie wörtlich von horden der bahn
sprechen zeigt das doch dass wir von der
gesellschaft ausgegrenzt
tatsächlich haben der ex militär fabry
berner duck und seine mitunterzeichner
wörtlich von horten der boni gesprochen
ist ihr begriff hause nicht
diskriminieren und stigmatisierend was
ist die definition einer horde das ist
eine gewalttätige gruppe und wir haben
es dort mit gewalttätigen gruppen zu tun
sehr gewaltig wenn wir den begriff
abschwächen sollen um ihnen dort eine
freude zu machen bitte sehr
aber das ändert nichts an der situation
unser ziel heute ist euch unser neues
ausbildungsprogramm vorzustellen im
jugendzentrum von trommler suchen
bewohner hilfe beim berufseinstieg viele
wollen etwas aus sich machen aber das
gerede über die boni erschwert das
spielt auch rassismus mit rein bei der
vergabe von jobs gibt es diskriminierung
aufgrund von nach namen und fotos aber
ich glaube das größte problem ist die
negative soziale darstellung von jungen
menschen aus den vorstädten
wir fragen den ehemaligen soldaten ob
seine sprache und seine aktion nicht
auch rassistisch seien
klar man ist immer rassist so einfach
ist das wenn sie jemanden in verruf
bringen wollen sagen sie er sei rassist
und da die franzosen angst haben halten
sie dann die klappe widerspruch bekommen
die 55 generäle und tausende andere
militärs die den appell von jean pierre
fabre berner doug unterzeichnet haben
nicht nur aus der branche sondern auch
von den spitzen der regierung
ich kann diese initiative nur mit der
größten entschlossenheit verurteilen
die initiative gehe und sie richtet sich
gegen all unsere republikanischen
prinzip gegen die ehre und die pflicht
der armee wobei diese generelle für
niemanden außer sich selbst stellt
gemeinde eine attacke von generälen
gewalt und soziale probleme frankreich
und seine frau news das ist eine
beziehung von urteilen und vorurteilen
abgrenzung und ausgrenzung der
heraufziehenden
präsidentschaftswahlkampf für da wohl
nicht beruhigen
[Musik]